Hey, YouTubers is Charlie. We're almost there hbo dropped a new preview
So let's break it down this will be a top 10 video. Just careful for spoilers for everything that's happened
So far if you're just finding me for the first time or you haven't been around since season 6
Welcome back be sure to subscribe to get everything and make sure you turn alerts on so you don't miss any of the videos
They'll be giveaway stuff happening this season
I'll explain at the end of the video and I'll also explain my video schedule
Because there'll be more stuff happening before we get episode 1 on Sunday, so because they dropped a bunch of episode 1 stuff
Let's break this down
I'll just do top 10 style like I'm going to do my episode videos
Starting with number 10 Mira and bran make it back to the wall. I love the look on her face here
It's so priceless like she is just so ready to be done with this and a lot of you've been asking me what I think
The first shot of episode 1 is going to be I think the seasons going to begin and end at the wall means that one
of the first things
We'll see is this moment here with them crossing blown to castle black
And then the final moments will be of something really crazy happening at the wall
We can talk about more end of the season predictions as we get on but number 9 in conjunction with that
Brands Relative state is a human potato
He's the three-eyed raven and him returning to winterfell has huge implications, but it sounds like the way
They're balancing Daenerys his character like she has ultimate power literally. She is so OP (OVER POWERED) right now with those dragons
There's only a couple ways the lannisters could fight them so
Brand being one of those other characters that has ultimate power too. Need some balance, so it sounds like the way
They did that is to turn him into something of a human potato so he can communicate with other people
Mira is able to speak to him when he's having his visions
But it sounds like he's going to be spending more and more of his time in these visions
Learning things using his power trying to suss out what the knight king is doing so Mira is left to the task of just
Dragging him around while he's catatonic
He has so much information that he needs to convey so I think he'll have
Moments of Lucidity you see him in the chair later in the trailer, so obviously that happens when he gets back to Winterfell
But I don't think he's going to be in any kind of state to be any kind of leader so like if you saw Spider-Man
Homecoming ned leaves is Peter Parker's man in the chair bran is the ultimate Man in the chair
He's very literally sitting in the chair once he does get back to winterfell you have that stark Reunion moment
Oh my God, bran you're still alive, but what's happened to you and they sort of get over that initial meeting?
He probably spends most of his time in the godswood with his hand on the weirwood using his power
But number seven the look on Ed's face here don't forget that
he's now Lord commander of the nights watch as
appointed by jon snow when he took off my watch is over now their numbers are down because they
Executed all the mutinous brothers last season, so it seems like Mira has a lot of fun trying to explain
What happened last season what they've been doing north of the wall
In how the night king is on their coattails and they need to start getting ready
And he just has this crazy look on his face when she dumps all this information on him
And I know a lot of you were looking at her sword hilt here because it's featured so prominently
There was a fun. Theory that she might actually be wielding the bloodraven sword dark sister
Which is one of the ancient targaryen Valyrian blade that was passed down?
It's very possible, but I don't think you can ascertain that just from looking at the hilt here
But the important thing to remember about valyrian swords because a lot of people always talk about
Longclaw like maybe Longclaw is actually dark sister
Because when the old bear gave longclaw to jon snow he had a new hilt put on it, so even though
It's incredibly hard to reforge valyrian steel much less make it. It's actually much easier to put a new hilt on it
So you could have a valyrian sword and just change the hilt and pass it from person to person
Moving along though number seven Daenerys lands on Dragonstone foregone conclusion the title of the episode is
Dragonstone it's 59 minutes long meaning that I think we're going to hit most of all the characters. There are a few characters
I don't think we'll see which I'll talk about later
But we've seen a whole bunch of shots of Daenerys
Riding up looking at the gates as they open walking straight up into her throne room
So it seems like that's the first place that she goes then she makes her way to the map table room where she starts thinking
About her battle plan in number six Circe's floor map being painted here
it looks like there's a parallel between their two storylines in the episode where Daenerys starts planning her battle as
Cersei starts planning her battles to the game of thrones premiere was last night
They had a big after-party the dancefloor was painted to look like the giant map of westeros that cersei has it was really cool
In number five as we've seen a lot of behind the scenes shots
It seems like Jaime is still with her for at least most of the first episode before he goes off and starts leading their army
The relative state of their arcs is really interesting because as lena headey the actress explains that Jamie is
hopelessly devoted to cersei at the beginning of the season
But we know based on the description for episode three that he comes to his senses
And something really bad happens because Lena headey has been hyping up how
Excited she is for Cersei going nuts this season
Which is the most terrible person you could imagine?
So even though you have all these characters trying to tell Jaime that Cersei is horrible
And he needs to be a good person like brienne or tyrion trying to get him to do the honorable thing
But he has steadfastly remain committed to cersei you love who you love but it sounds like at some point
She's going to do something so bad that he'll say enough is enough, but one of the coolest things this season
I think is seeing the rise of Jaime has a battle commander so most of the shots that we see him in are either with
Cersei or riding on the battlefield leading the Lannister army you think back to season four how Jamie was
Obsessed with the white book doing something great worthy of having his deeds honored in the book the way Barristan selmy
Or the other great kingsguard had I think while cercei  is on this downward spiral of Craziness
Jaime is actually headed on his way up, but obviously you know he already narrated his own death
I want to die in the arms of someone I love
So I will do a death predictions video in the next couple of days
He's not really high on my list for this season
I think a lot of the big deaths will be pushed to season eight, but number four back up at Winterfell
I think it's also a bit of a metaphor for how the seasons going to start off up there with them slowly
Chasing their tails fighting each other a little bit before team stark comes together and they have their big payoff
But separately you also see the little bear looking like she's mouthing off giving one of her big speeches
So it sounds like they also waste no time in
arguing about what to do next in the wake of the battle of the bastards
So they still have to deal with the karstarks the umbers the people that were loyal to the Bolton's
What are they going to do with their territories and what are they going to do with the wildlings?
Because while they have named jon snow king of the north and even sansa's sort of co ruling
with him they still don't like the
Wildlings that much so they're not going to be very happy if John tries to grant them a bunch of land
So even though we've moved past the book plot like we are in uncharted territory
There are a lot of theories that they might use the Alice Karstark twist from the books and it'll be some sort of alliance
That's forged through marriage to one of the wildlings normally that would be tormund, giantsbane
But he's actually pretty high on my death
Predictions list so I don't know if he's going to be getting married to anyone anytime soon regardless of the way it went down in
The books but separately number three it seems like littlefinger will waste no time in putting his grand plan into motion creating Chaos
Amongst the starks he always has a number of plans like he says to sansa side when he narrates in the trailer fight every battle
Everywhere in your mind at the same time, but then she narrates the lone wolf dies
But the pack survives so you can kind of see what his arc this season is he's one of those lone wolves that's going to
Die because the pack the stark children are meant to come together
He's also really high in my death predictions list, but a lot of people ask about his plans
I do think that he's back dealing with Cersei in case his plans with Sansa and the North fall through he always has multiple irons
in the fire playing all sides against each other so as much fun as it'll see to watch him be as devious as
Possible what I'm really excited about is when Aria finally has her big reunion
And he tries to play all of the stark children
Against each other and to see how jon snow and Aria deal with that because it looks like sansa
is slowly getting used to littlefinger
She's been with him for so long, but Aria and Jon Snow do not suffer fools
The same way that sansa's been forced to
But number two what about the army of the dead all the night king the white walker shots that we've seen look like they've been
From the heat of battle which implies that they're much later in this season, so just as we've had with previous seasons
It sounds like we'll slowly feel their presence more and more as we get deeper into the season
I'm expecting full-time compression to be in effect north of the wall, what'll probably happen in the south
Is that you'll see characters travelling around really fast between episodes?
But even though the night king in the army of the dead isn't that far from the wall
They're not just going to walk up and park it there all season long
He's waiting for brand to cross with his mark
So that the magical enchantment will be broken and he can bring the wall
crumbling down
all the shots we've seen to them so far are of people that haven't made it to the north yet fighting them north of the
Wall so I'm expecting there to be lots of questions about what the night king was doing for the first couple of episodes
If Bran had already made it south of the wall like why is he waiting to come bring the wall crumbling down?
The big reason I think will be so that you can end on the dramatic moment of him either
Cracking the wall or bringing a crumbling down something with him destroying part of the wall and then them cutting to black before
Season 8 because like I said I think will begin the season and end the season with scenes at the wall
But number one there's a whole bunch of characters that we haven't mentioned here that don't appear in the previews Samwell Jorah
Benjin Arya the Brotherhood
So I think that most of those characters will be in episode one briefly
Mostly Arya stark all the main characters tend to get preference
But the Brotherhood and arya are slowly making their way north separately samwell is the citadel training to become a maester
It does seem like gilly based on the previews will be the one that finds out accidental information about a zora
Hi, so you have a lot of really big mythology that they need to convey this season to people like Jon
Snow the Prince was promised the son of Liana and Rhaegar
So it seems like most of that information won't get sucked out until everybody converges in Samwell makes his way back door
But I think that half of that will come from Samwell through book learning that he finds out at the citadel in brand who's literally?
Experiencing this in flashbacks, but if anybody is going to save sir Jorah
It's got to be samwell which makes you wonder why the other Maesters haven't learned to cure
greyscale better like if Samwell just shows up in a single season and
Suddenly learns how to cure greyscale then why is it that all these other maesters haven't learned that yet, and if they do cure
Sir George greyscale, what was the point in giving it to him in the first place anyway?
So just remember all those things as those storylines play out and has for benjin
I don't expect to see him again until we go back north of the wall later in the season and he is also on my
Death predictions list I think that anybody that goes north of the wall is marked for death unless their name is Jon. Snow and Daenerys
So what will happen is my next video will be my death predictions that will either post Friday or Saturday
But leave all your bonus video requests in the comments below my episode 1 video will post after the episode Airs Sunday night
All my episode videos will post right after the episode there, then I'll do trailer videos on Monday
Then I'll do Q&A videos and anything else you guys want the hBO now giveaway will be happening every week congratulations
to the latest winner Ryan Springer
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
I'll announce the next winner in the next video that I post while you wait for everything click here for the newest promo and you
Can click here for all my season 7 videos thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight